the liberal media is hammering Joe Biden
for snubbing an audience of 100 million
Americans and skipping the traditional
Super Bowl interview for the second year
in a row it seems like a no-brainer
bring your reelection message to a
massive audience of potential voters but
some in the Press say that the big baby
in the White House just can't handle it
I couldn't figure out that Super Bowl
interview uh passing on that he can
really get his message out to an
audience just sitting waiting for him
waiting for his message is telling is it
because he can't handle it if he is not
able to follow the questions if his
staff is worried that he can connect the
dots and find the word that he's looking
for that's a problem he's giving up an
opportunity to talk to millions of
people this Sunday turning down a pre-
Super Bowl interview he will never have
that size audience again and make his
case but maybe there's a good reason why
the White House wants to hide Biden it
would be a total disaster Joe Biden has
been racking up some really embarrassing
gaps lately like forgetting the name of
the terror group Hamas and claiming to
have met with a French president who
died almost 30 years
ago there's been a
response from the
opposition but
um yes I'm sorry from Hamas right right
after I was elected I went to what they
call a G7 meeting and I sat down and I
said America's back and meeran from
Germany I mean from France looked at me
and
said uh said you
know what why how long you back
for even the White House is having a
hard time defending Biden's embarrassing
Mix-Ups how is President Biden ever
going to convince the 3/4 of Voters who
are worried about his physical and
mental health that he is okay even
though in Las Vegas he told a story
about recently talking to a French
president who died in
1996 I'm not even going to go down that
rabbit hole with you sir Rabbit Hole he
said he talk to Minon you saw the
president in Vegas in California you've
seen the president in South Carolina you
saw him in M Michigan I'll just leave it
there but there's one president who
would gladly do the Super Bowl interview
Donald Trump says he would be happy to
replace Biden and that it would be
ratings gold but so far the chairman of
CBS Sports which is hosting the game is
shutting down the
idea um okay Dana this year's Super Bowl
they say is estimated to bring in almost
200 million viewers the most ever yeah
you think of all those Swifty fans that
are going to be watching yeah and what a
missed opportunity for reelection
efforts it is so i' I've said yesterday
I I'm okay if this tradition goes away
compl completely um president Trump
didn't do it in 2018 and I think that's
probably if I recall correctly it was
like like unlikely to be a fair
interview in his mind Biden gets very
fair interviews in fact reporters even
help him out by saying that you know
it's Hamas or the Hamas is who we're
talking about and I get that I was just
telling Greg I I did that in school all
the time if I I would have sympathy for
people who couldn't come up with the
answer so I would whisper it and try to
help them like you don't really should
you shouldn't really do that for a
president presid of the United States
who's doing an interview especially when
23% of people in the NBC poll said that
Biden has the necessary physical and
mental strength to be president 23% so I
understand also that every interview is
a risk opportunity so if there's a high
risk but there's also really high reward
if you do it well so imagine if he came
out he did the three-minute interview as
Jesse was saying he Nails it I was like
wow so all those people who are worried
that he doesn't have the mental strength
and capacity can um maybe put that aside
and think about the issues but I think
the White House has calculated that the
risk is so great that he won't be able
to nail it and it could even be
disastrous that it would do irreparable
harm and if they want to get him
reelected they'll keep him off big
interviews like that you know Jesse we
we first heard that they were they had
this kind of seran wrap approach you
know they were going to keep him wrapped
up and not let him out but for the past
couple of weeks they've been saying you
know Joe's going to come out Joe's going
to come out uh but I think this latest
midan and Hamas gaps uh do you think
that they've decided to go in the other
direction because there's too much risk
to an unscripted interview yeah I mean
that would have second thoughts after I
see dead
people I'd stay in Delaware the next
weekend the media is there to help
Democrats not hide Democrats this is a
business Donald Trump made the careers
of dozens of people in the Press Joe
Biden is destroying the Press have you
seen all of these companies are laying
off thousands of media people thousands
of them don't have jobs anymore when you
had Trump as president you had action
you had access you had excitability
people got shows on cable they wrote
books they became millionaires that's
because Trump engaged it's no fun to
cover a campaign when the president
doesn't campaign these people have seen
real campaigns Clinton Bush Obama Trump
some of the most vigorous and active
bully pulpit exploiters there ever was
and then you have a guy a slumber party
at first in 2020 is like okay we played
along and hit him because of Co and
Trump was the devil they're not going to
do that again they're not going to hide
him when there's no Co so I think you're
seeing the media start to be torn a
little bit you see two business
reporters saying what's this guy doing
and you're also going to see CBS Strike
Back CBS is going to be happy that the
sitting president just dissed them on
Super Bowl Sunday they're going to start
talking about this they need somebody to
go on their shows you can't have a
president who's a Democrat and all these
Democrat anchors have no one to talk to
this is a problem you're going to see it
start shifting pretty soon it can't go
on much more like this you know tulsey I
mean if the president can't handle uh an
interview during the Super Bowl or to be
played during the Super Bowl what do you
think he's saying or speaking to when
he's talking to to XI jingping or when
he's talking to Putin or if he if does
he talk to them I I think uh good
question but but really to me this is
such a missed opportunity because again
this is the Super Bowl ideally you have
a relationship between the president
commander-in-chief and the American
people and voters and this is an
opportunity to connect with a couple
hundred million people in this country
um you know he either doesn't feel
connected or maybe maybe he thinks that
football fans are Maga Trump supporters
I don't know what it is but it is an
incredibly missed opportunity to be able
to speak directly to the American people
and I think it is a sign that his
handlers don't trust him and they will
look to uh the basement strategy that he
used last time because they don't want
him to be held to account for his
failures to the American people whether
it's border security uh rampant crime
inflation increasing cost of living uh
these are the issues that he needs to be
confronted on and I think they're afraid
they're afraid to put him in the
spotlight all right did CBS make a
mistake in not entertaining Trump's
decision or request oh yeah and I'm
going to get to that in a second but
this interview is perfect for Joe
because it's a
no-brainer uh and we showed we showed
like this Montage of all of his
gibberish and we call them gaffs those
are not gaffs because gaffs suggest that
they are rare or unusual what is rare
and unusual is when he makes sense it's
funny when you mention Gaff that's when
you can actually understand what Joe is
saying and what kind of questions do
they think are going to trip him up
what's your name I mean what is what are
they worried about when they ask him
what's his favorite Super Bowl snack are
they worried that he's going to say
francea Mand
look they could do it at his house Jill
could be next to him a medical
professional right literally he has to
be conscious for three minutes right
surely there's a drug for that call
Hunter he's got something lying around
maybe the White House still has that
baggie of Coke in the evidence room who
knows but um it's weird it's like Joe
not doing the Super Bowl interview sends
a horrible message that's far worse than
if he did it and screwed up because it's
saying I can't do it it's like ducking
an interview with a magic eightball uh
imagine the only way to sell a product
is by hiding it from the public you know
it's like imagine doing merch for your
band
and your t-shirt is completely blank
because you don't want them to hear the
music it's crazy so I think they have a
great opportunity to to take Trump on
his offer and we mentioned it here first
but the interview if it doesn't happen
Trump should do it anyway and you know
who
with me you Donald we do a halftime
interview you pick the place we'll do it
we'll do it 5 minutes 10 minutes it'll
be great just counter program that's
what you're known for I'm not doing
anything Sunday I don't even know who's
playing I think they're setting the
stage for the big reveal which is no
debates with Trump absolutely that's
what this is I have to say also if you
had asked me and I'm fairly Lucid who
who was the French president in the
1990s I would like uh I don't know
starts with an m I might have been able
to come up with Mand I don't know so
that was a real weird throwback and I
still don't know what the rabbit hole is
KJ was talking about she GNA say yeah
well I don't know what else she could
possibly say well hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now